la trêve aura été de courte durée
instaurer le 22 février elle n'aura été
respectée que neuf jours par les taliban
qui ont annoncé lundi reprendre leur
offensive contre les forces de sécurité
afghanes
nos moudjahidine n'attaqueront pas les
forces étrangères mais nos opérations
continueront contre les forces du
gouvernement de kaboul
une annonce qui intervient deux jours
seulement après la signature d'un accord
historique entre les taliban et
washington cet accord doit permettre
d'amorcer un retrait des forces
américaines
un texte qui n'est pas synonyme d'un
arrêt total et immédiat des violences
alerte le pentagone ce lundi j'invite
tout le monde à intégrer le fait qu'il
ne va pas y avoir une cessation absolu
de la violence en afghanistan
cela ne va probablement pas arrivé on ne
va pas aboutir à un niveau zéro de la
violence cet accord est un pas en avant
important qui va conduire à un dialogue
inter afghan et au bout du compte un
accord de paix mais penser qu'il va
immédiatement mettre fin à la violence
cela n'arrivera pas peu de temps après
l'annonce des talibans la police afghane
a affirmé qu'une attaque avait fait
trois morts et 11 blessés dans l'est du
pays sans en préciser le responsable
une moto piégée a explosé pendant un
match de football dans le district de
nadir shah kot cet après midi
trois civils ont été tués et onze autres
blessés pourtant le président afghan
ashraf ghani avait annoncé dimanche la
prolongation de la trêve partiel elle
devait durer au moins jusqu'au début des
discussions en terre afghane qui doivent
débuter le 10 mars